president biden says he does not think
russian leader vladimir putin is testing
him
with another major ransomware attack
this time against a major meat
processing company
but the strike against jbs comes on the
heels of a devastating attack
against an american pipeline company and
just ahead of the first summit
between the two leaders national
security correspondent jennifer griffin
has the latest from the pentagon good
evening jennifer good evening brett the
most recent russian
ransomware attack targeted meat packing
plants from north america to australia
some workers returned to their shifts
this evening in colorado and nebraska
but it's not clear when all nine
processing plants here in the u.s will
be back at full capacity
raising concerns about how long this
will last and who will pay
the cyber attack on the world's largest
meat supplier comes less than a month
after the colonial pipeline hack
president biden says he plans to raise
the issue
with vladimir putin when he meets with
the russian president
in geneva in two weeks mr president will
you retaliate against russia for this
latest ransomware attack
do you think putin is testing you
white house press secretary jenn saki
says ransomware attacks have been rising
in recent weeks
president biden certainly thinks that
president putin and the russian
government has a role to play
in stopping and preventing these attacks
one of the country's leading cyber
experts says russia has ignored u.s
requests in the past
the russian government is allowing them
to operate within their country they
have refused over the years to
extradite those people or even to arrest
them and at some point we need to start
holding them accountable
jbs has more than 50 billion dollars in
annual sales worldwide and accounts for
20
of all the beef poultry and pork sold in
the u.s
its american headquarters is in greeley
colorado an
hour north of denver so far there have
been no meat shortages and the company
says
a majority of operations will resume
today our systems are coming back online
and we are not sparing any resources to
fight this threat
jbs said in a statement the disruption
couldn't come at a worse time for
restaurant owners
who say meat prices as a result of the
pandemic are already at a six-year high
here's one of our prime grade briskets
this piece of meat would have cost us
about fifty dollars here in the
restaurant
just in march today we're paying about
ninety dollars dimitri alperovich says
the white house must go after the
payment source for cyber criminals
cryptocurrency the reason why we're
seeing so much of these ransom
and extortion campaigns is because the
criminals now have a way
to collect these payments in a basically
pseudo-anonymous fashion
just weeks ago colonial pipeline paid
4.4 million dollars to its russian
hackers
using cryptocurrency and we've just
learned of a new ransomware attack today
targeting the steamship authority in
woods hole massachusetts that ferries
vacationers back and forth to nantucket
and martha's vineyard
officials say hackers also infiltrated
the metropolitan transportation
authority in new york in
april but the mta said it quickly shut
down the breach
brett jennifer griffin at the pentagon
jennifer thank you